hello everyone
welcome to rational science
and i hope transmission is good today
had problems last time i have no idea
what happens something related to i
guess youtube so uh please let me know
if you can hear me if you can see me i'm
a little worried about that because i'm
concentrating on my on what i got to
talk about and you know here are all
these other little things going on
with good ol uh youtube
so please let me know if you can't hear
me or if you can't hear me loud enough i
had problems with that as well
okay meanwhile let me continue first of
all happy new year to everyone and i
guess everyone
made some kind of uh
some made some kind of resolution new
year's resolution
and
uh no problems okay thank you
um made your new year's resolution i
made a resolution i won't
shave
for the first few days of the year okay
so that was my resolution
and i'm
uh really following up on that okay
anyways um we had a great year of uh
what is it called
uh-huh
okay thank you
um we had a great year of covid and we
went from what um
the delta to the omicron okay we're now
in the omicron age and who knows what
good things
uh come up ahead
i i received a call today from my niece
and she told me she was in contact with
two people who had kovit okay who were
tested positive for covid
and i told her you know that's kind of
suspicious you know because this is um
flu season
you know this this is the season to be
jolly right
and um and so it just happens that uh
this
uh you know this these people started
feeling some symptoms
so they went and got a test and the test
came out positive
and the question i've got is whether
they just had the common flu
and it's being mistaken for this covet
thingy i mean i don't know enough about
all this stuff but it is suspicious to
me that nobody talks about the flu
anymore
now what's you know on the news is cobit
and you know what happened to the poor
old flu i mean
the flu bug
so you know i don't know and she was
concerned because you know uh we
argentines you know we we drink mate
okay and we all drink out of the same uh
guard okay
and the same uh straw metal straw
okay it's a uh it's not really a tea
it's a social
uh drink social it's i call it an excuse
you know we drink mate to get together
in other words you don't say to someone
um
come over to my house and we're going to
talk business
that's too blunt
and so what we say is why don't you come
over to my house and we'll have some
mate
so that's the reason we're getting
together we're getting together to have
mate and in the course of you know
drinking mate we talk about girls and
football and business that's how it
works so she was concerned you know that
maybe she could have infected me
but she's uh she says she's clean she's
negative so she doesn't understand that
either so
that's the situation anyways i hope none
of you get covered whatever that is
maybe it's just a regular flu some
people have died of it maybe there's a
uh stronger strain of flu out there
maybe it was manufactured in wuhan or
maybe the american
cia built it and then took it over to
humuhan who knows
you know it all depends on what you want
to believe right now i don't know what
to believe
all i know i got the shots because i
need to travel and i don't want the
hassle and so let's i hope i don't need
any more boosters but they keep
inventing all these boosters and then
some people say well we don't have the
booster works and i'm talking about
doctors saying this okay some people say
it works some people say don't
and what do you do
okay
uh yeah anyways uh
we only we not only have a war against
the bugs
we seem to be
confronting what is known as a civil war
you know there was a civil war in the
united states uh what was it 1860 all
the way to 65 until they killed lincoln
and um
and then now they say we're we're going
to have a second war and this is what it
looks like let me put it over here
okay it says the next u.s civil war is
already here we just refuse to see it
okay so is there gonna be another civil
war the right against the left or the
uh
pro-covit against the anti-covid
what's it gonna be okay
uh
you know uh and that's not the only war
that might come around this year we
might have a different war and that's
gonna be one that's gearing up over
there in ukraine
you know uh apparently uh they're having
some talks and hopefully
they all reach you know
their senses
and uh they all agreed to you know to
not have a war okay now you have that
other war looming over there in taiwan
and i was telling people because a lot
of people are not aware of this and i
think i should make them aware of it
okay when i was working at amd we worked
with a company to which we
subcontracted stuff
and that was taiwan semiconductor known
as tsm
and
taiwan semiconductor
has become i think the number one
company in the world that manufactures
chips
now okay
uh it's a foundry what they call you
know uh
uh
a factory that produces chips in fact uh
amd doesn't produce chips anymore uh
what they do is do design
and then they subcontract all the work
to other companies among them uh taiwan
semiconductor
and
you know being the number one company in
the world or close to it or one of the
ones the important ones it's in taiwan i
think it's in taipei
uh it turns out that not only do they
produce the chips
very the most sophisticated ships you
can imagine
but um
it has the know-how on how to produce
them
turns out that mainland china you know
the communist china
uh these folks are maybe a few years
behind
the west on chip manufacturing despite
my help
they're still behind
and you know
what better prize is there in taiwan
today than catching or grabbing a hold
of taiwan's semiconductor
just imagine that would happen to fall
into chinese hands
you would be killing two birds with one
stone
the first one is that
they would be in charge of the company
that produces the most chips or one of
the ones that produces the most chips
and suddenly they gain eight years or
five years or whatever amount of time
they're behind in development research r
d you know
uh they gain all that time all of a
sudden and suddenly they catch up
so and right now there's a chip
there uh you know across the planet
especially for cars
and imagine if the uh
chinese had the faucet to turn that on
and off
they would have a little bit of power
right
so uh i would say that if the chinese
are going after taiwan it's not only to
conquer their territory back and say
it's part of china you know that's
like politics yeah that's great
i think there are some prizes that you
go after
uh and i'll just give you an example why
did the united states abandon
afghanistan
well if afghanistan had taiwan
semiconductor in in its place you know
had all this
great technology
the americans would not have abandoned
uh afghanistan
afghanistan was abandoned because
there's nothing to steal there
what are you gonna steal camels
so there's nothing in afghanistan that's
the problem and taiwan it does have some
things i'm saying the number one thing
they've got is taiwan's semiconductor
keep that in mind okay i'm saying that's
part of the chinese plan i think it is
you know
and so just
you know for you to ponder
okay uh when follow says
we must shut down the economy because
the capitalist model has reached the end
of the line
where increased uh profits can no longer
be sustained
we are being led into the slave economy
the so-called you know uh great reset i
called it the
great resignation or you know because a
lot of people are abandoning their jobs
the population must be called down to a
manageable level where there are just
enough slaves
now you know who you are you're a slave
right modern slave
to run the uh the machines grow the food
maintain the infrastructure etc
you know uh
what i see is a lot of people involved
in politics and all i can tell you is
get out of politics as soon as you can
you know i made a lot of mistakes in my
life and one of them was getting
involved in politics of a very early age
i mean i was involved in politics since
the age of 15. i would read the
newspaper every day that young at that
young in age
and you know i went in the socialist way
i was leftist no one could have been
more leftist than me at the time you
know i read just about anything that
lenin wrote he was my hero right
uh so was fidel castro but lenin was a
little more uh
it was more of a writer
of ideas and so was marx for that matter
but uh
one thing i learned in my life don't get
involved in politics get out of politics
and people like to do politics they say
oh the illuminati the new world order
people you know the what is it the uh
the skeletons over there
can't remember the the phrase but all
these people who belong to these secret
societies you know uh bo uh what the
bones
uh the cross the
skull and bones that's what i wanted to
say the skull and bones you know all
these all these secret societies you
know out there and they're saying oh
they're dominating us they have all this
money all this power blah blah blah
you know um
my my argument here okay you don't have
to believe it but that's just so you
understand the argument i'm saying
there's no one that can do anything
about extinction
no one can do anything about saving the
economy the global economy the economy
will
fail no matter what and when it does not
if but when it does
uh the rich will be as rich as you are
and you say well they won't let it
happen
it's like they can't do anything about
it okay it's not something they have
control over
okay the global economy cannot grow
forever
that's the issue
and partly part of the reason for that
is you need demand and what we're not
producing is demand right now we're not
producing population which is ultimately
the demand and so companies expect to
sell more next year and they're going to
be selling less less and less and less
their marginal uh profits are going to
be you know
again it's going to be marginal profits
why because
uh
fewer people buy and second where most
people are becoming poorer okay there's
very few rich people and
the masses of people are becoming poorer
okay that's just a fact look it up
anywhere you want that's that's the
trend and there's nothing that can
change all that especially we all go on
the internet to try to do some business
to try to make some money and so this is
the issue you cannot have people with
fewer and fewer real value in their
salaries and
buying fewer and fewer things which are
important things like cars or houses or
whatever
and at the same time you know you have
the global economy it's not growing
because you don't have people demanding
okay so that has to reach a point where
you know it it grows asymptotically and
at some point it collapses it reaches a
zenith and that's it that's it for all
of us okay so i'm saying no one can do
anything about it i don't give the
illuminati
stand on their heads okay they can't do
anything about this problem all they can
do at best is stretch it out as much as
they can and i do pray they do
please extend it as much as you can
cheat lie whatever you have to but
extend it okay so that our lives are
a little longer and after that we're all
done you know nothing we can do about it
okay another foul says extrapolate means
prediction he's saying that my
extinction theory
is about uh predicting
uh-huh and uh another guy uh doubles up
on that and he says the following
says uh bill your theory about the
extinction of the human species is a
prediction
theory is an ex a prediction
doesn't sound right okay you can fool
peop you can't fool people with
terms uh
in terms of words or absurd denials open
your dictionary sometime come on
[Laughter]
and so yeah you look up the word predict
and says you know announcing previously
verbally orient writing right
the coming true of future things okay
essentially that's it
and so you've got all these version
prophetic divine paranormal etc right so
you have all these ways of predicting
okay
some people had a bad dream they say i
predict god came and talked to me at
night while i was sleeping
okay
so what can i say to that well here let
me show you this is my argument on that
and the first one is that we look up
this word prediction and you find some
synonyms there you find prophecy
uh
actually the verb to prophesy okay uh
predict foretell presage
portend and so on so you get all these
synonyms out there but all these
synonyms are not exactly synonyms okay
there are a little bit of a few
differences between them like uh to
prophesy is usually you know uh when
when a person
does it through
or or has as a basis
some supernatural thing you know at
least that's the notion we have a
prophecy okay that god came in and
whispered in your ears or that you know
you you had a shot in your arm and
suddenly you see the light you know
those kinds of things so you had a
supernatural uh experience or
extraordinary experience okay
and so suddenly you see
the world you see the future in fact if
you see read revelations in the bible i
think you'll see a lot of that i don't
know what the guy was on to but
he saw the future
but where did he get the information was
it a uh sound reasoning uh was he um
reasoning uh the thing out does he have
a basis does he have a rational
foundation for what he's saying for what
he's predicting prophecying prophesying
okay
and no the answer is no these people
don't have that and so that's uh a
little bit where we distinguish what i'm
doing okay from what these people are
doing
okay so let me show you something here
give me a second here
let me get uh madame bill out of there
okay uh
here we have it okay
is a theory a prediction
any issues no it's not because a theory
is an explanation and a prediction is a
description okay
you make a prediction
and here's the prediction even even
though it's
it's doesn't involve supernatural stuff
you make a prediction you say tomorrow
at two o'clock
there's gonna be an eclipse
okay we tested it turns out tomorrow two
o'clock there was an eclipse okay it
happened there it is okay
so the guy made a
prediction so far all he did was
describe describe that's all he did
he hasn't explained why
there's going to be
you know an eclipse
and you say well
how did he know that
well the only way he knew that knew no
understand explain right
is that he's seen or he's been in
contact or
or he he had an experience
with this knowledge with this
incident this type of incidence in the
past
past
okay what's past
past means
time that happened before us not the
future the past okay we explain the past
we predict the future
so the guy's making a prediction but
what does he base it on
not on god not on the spirits talking to
him he's basing it on he's saying look
every 10 years we have this
eclipse
and it's always comes on the 1st of july
and so this year 10 years later 1st of
july there's going to be an eclipse and
there's the eclipse
okay so so why why does he know that he
knows it because of past experience
so he can explain to you look it
happened okay
it or it's gonna happen or it did happen
if once you
were there at two o'clock and saw it
happen you say it happened because every
ten years we have this on the first of
july
okay that still doesn't tell us why what
happened physically it just tells us
that you know i've been following this
thing over and over and every 10 years
it happens so i know it's gonna happen
again
okay so that's all he's got but so far
he hasn't explained the mechanism
the mechanism would be you know what
happens is the the
moon
goes in between the earth and the sun
except for flat earthers
uh between the earth and the sun and it
causes this uh
shadow
now we have a mechanism okay so at
different levels of
theory
but theory is an explanation you're
trying to explain a mechanism okay and
that's what this fellow doesn't
understand there there or these two
followers they're harping on prediction
okay they say oh yours is a prediction
no it ain't okay
and uh yeah it's a bad habit of the
religion of mathematics mathematics okay
and again he spoke they're focusing on
the wrong aspect when we talk about
prediction
in the context of the extinction of man
when i say man will
go extinct okay i'm not talking about
prediction okay you're focusing on the
wrong aspect i'm saying
it will because i'm going to be
explaining to you why man cannot avoid
extinction
i'm giving you a full proof
mechanism for why man is going to die
our species is gonna disappear
okay
and so the issue is not when you're
focusing on the wrong thing when you're
saying when
what time the future you're thinking of
future no no think of mechanism not of
time
okay
the issue is mechanism issue is what if
man encounters the same predicament as
the the animals in the past like the
dinosaurs for example the most famous
case right
can man overcome the situation with
intelligence
technology uh
ability
to foresee events and react to them okay
can man do anything about the mechanism
of extinction
because if you cannot do anything about
the mechanism of extinction it will
happen
and if it will happen it's not a
prediction because we're not talking
about saying oh
you know i'm predicting i'm
uh prophesying i'm saying this is what's
going to happen in the future no you're
focusing on the wrong aspect the aspect
is this is the mechanism we cannot avoid
that that's the argument so when you
focus on prediction you're focusing on
the wrong issue okay
and so here's a list that i made just
impromptu list of things
uh man can't do anything about
i don't care how much intelligence man
has i don't care how much technology man
has i don't care if you can foresee
events and react to them and
and we invent robots and whatever
whatever whatever i don't care you can't
do anything about these issues that i'm
going to point out here i'm just going
to give you a quick list okay so
uh bear in mind and you can think of a
lot more i'm sure okay but here they are
okay things man can't do anything about
i don't care if you're rich i don't care
if you're the illuminati i don't care if
you're the new world order people you
can't do anything about this
i don't care how intelligent you are
okay having children we're not gonna
have children anymore okay we're having
fewer and fewer children and there's a
lot of reasons for that i'm not gonna go
into all of them but the main one i
guess is that people go into the cities
cities is you have density dependent
birth rates there's culture there's
money there's several things involved in
you have fewer children so right now the
growth rate of the global global
population is coming down and that
includes the african nations south
american nations which spit out kids no
they have big cities over there you
don't have people being born in buenos
aires you don't have people born in lima
peru you don't have people born in lagos
nigeria that's all falling to pieces
right now okay
and countries like the united states
australia canada their population is
still rising only because of immigration
okay so keep that in mind united states
if if they had no immigration the
population would uh slowly uh
become asymptotic and then fall okay
uh we can't do anything about inbreeding
okay
meaning that we're going to suffer loss
of more loss of genetic diversity okay
we don't produce more diversity we
produce less and less because of
inbreeding and whatever mutations we
have uh accumulate a lot
slower than the
inbreeding kills
okay that's my argument you don't have
to believe it i'm just saying that's
what i'm proposing here okay and so
these are things man can't do anything
about we have to inbreed we we can't
sleep with uh gorillas we can't sleep
with chimps there's no other humanoid or
human-like creature with which we can
have sex we can only do it with each
other and we've been doing that for 200
300 000 years so we can't avoid
inbreeding and the consequences
increase in homosexuality we can't avoid
that either okay and autism autism i i
put under autism all kinds of mental
defects okay i call it autism it doesn't
matter you some people are schizophrenia
authentic or whatever it doesn't matter
i'm saying you have mental problems you
have physical and mental problems both
growing old we can't do anything about
growing old and i don't mean just an
individual because that's true but our
species is growing old the population
pyramid of our species has been
overturning since 1963 as a whole for
the whole planet and we can't do
anything about it okay so look it up
you'll find it uh concentrating in
cities we cannot avoid moving to the
cities
we're never going back to the country
okay that's a one-way street
okay so we can't do anything we can't
say
you can't have a government saying okay
we're going to put people out in the
country now it's never going to happen
not in russia not in china any united
states nowhere
okay it's not going to happen anymore we
will be concentrating more and more into
towns building them into big
metropolises you know
the little towns are growing to grow
into cities and the cities will be mega
cities that's the way it's going
uh so we won't be returning to
agriculture we won't be uh
we can't avoid moving into the internet
economy
we will move into the internet economy
partly because a lot of people like it
but a lot of people are out of work and
they can't find other jobs that are well
paying i mean if they would triple the
salaries i'm sure a lot of people would
go out there and get jobs and i'll just
give you an example
delta and united
they had to cancel many flights over the
uh close to the end of the year
and
american airlines did something else
and i know this from the inside right
and that's that they tripled
300
the salaries of any flight attendant and
pilot
that did not call in sick
okay you got that so if you did not call
in sick which is very standard at the
end of the year everybody always calls
in sick at the end of the year because
they don't want to work
christmas or new year's those are sacred
days and so people don't want to work
and they say you got to work because
it's your ship
and so everybody calls in sick at the
end of the year and that's what happened
to delta and united but american
airlines offered 300 salaries 300 per
hour
no one they were fighting
for the for the trips
the the flight attendants were fighting
for for the trips they did not cancel
flights
so all the other
uh companies like united and delta big
companies uh they had a lot of covid
[Laughter]
they got all the covet but american
airlines did not get covered okay they
had their flights because the company
offered them 300 percent of their
salaries if they would come to work if
if they didn't call in sick
and the flight attendants were fighting
for
uh you know getting getting on the
planes okay
for working yeah and if you do that with
anybody any kind you do that at
mcdonald's you say we're gonna raise
your salary 300 percent i'm sure a lot
of people will stop having cobit and all
these other little thingies okay
okay uh so white for loss of real wages
we cannot avoid that traveling to the
nearest star can we do that absolutely
not no matter how you stand uh you can
stand on your head if you want you won't
travel to the nearest star
and traveling through time hopefully
nobody can travel through time
and we cannot avoid the extinction of
our species
now how's that for uh
prediction okay
i'm saying we cannot avoid any of those
no matter what we do no matter what
technology we have no matter how much
intelligence we have or how much we can
foresee events we cannot do anything
about those issues
and you're welcome to fight me okay on
that okay here's uh
something related to that okay uh what
have we done in these last few years
maybe 10 20 years we've abandoned the
jungle okay
for well this was originally you know
some 10 000 years ago we abandoned the
jungle went to agriculture then we
abandoned the farms agriculture and we
went into wet manufacturing industry
a few years ago we abandoned the
factories and we went to offices
now we're in the cities
you know we work in offices
we move the pencils around okay that's
what we do and not even that pencils
don't exist anymore now it's all
computer right
we've abandoned houses we've gone into
apartments for the most part okay
uh we've abandoned family we don't have
family now what we have is solitary
individuals nobody knows even who his
neighbor is anymore right
um
and we've abandoned dancing and sex
uh
in general you know we do a lot of
visual sex but not you know like real
sex we're abandoning that and turning
into games we're going into games
everybody's playing games these days
everybody's an expert on games
and everybody's eating the lotus like i
said you know uh good old uh odysseus
he uh his men ended up on an island the
lotus island they um they were eating a
lotus and they were just munching and
just
you know
with their minds out in
in in heaven i guess
and that's more or less the situation
today a lot of people are you know 10
feet off the ground
they don't have their feet on the ground
anymore they have no idea what reality
is a lot of them are drugs and a lot of
people are in worse
games which is worse than drugs
if you talk about uh one of the
big
problems of society today forget about
you know the
injectable drugs or sniffable drugs
uh how about games you know that that
really has gotten the new generation
everybody's stuck on games
if there's one industry that's booming
it could be that one okay
and again internet stuff
okay uh phil says this extinction
speculation doesn't make it
make it into the top 20 reasons mankind
may go extinct
absolutely right
so uh nobody has thought about this okay
and that's why you won't even find it in
the first 20 or the first hundred i mean
nobody has thought about the fact that
the economy is going to fall to pieces
and you know money will be no more so
yeah you came to this site you got it
right uh you're gonna learn a different
theory here that you won't hear anywhere
else okay you won't find it in the
wikipedia you won't find any blogs out
there
this is the only place where we talk
about this
mechanism of extinction so you're lucky
you're lucky because you were exposed to
it not because you believe it but you
were exposed to it now you can munch it
you know and
crunch it decide for your own for
yourself
money is a concept just like inches
pounds kilograms meters absolutely
correct we will never and cannot run
out of concept money
uh yeah okay most of our money isn't
even represented by something physical
yeah because it's a concept so
you know uh what you have is
uh yeah in a way he's right he's saying
they're you know
gold and even dollar bills or whatever
coins you know that's going out the door
we're replacing that with more
abstractions you know bitcoin and uh you
know where's all the money today in
checking accounts we're the checking
accounts on the internet
so let us hope mr poutine doesn't uh go
over there and uh you know send his
killer satellites because the day he
kills this killer sat he kills the
satellites that's the end of all of us
you know if he does that
uh suddenly you know there is no
internet
and that's where all our money is that's
the treasure treasure chest is the
internet right now okay you want to know
how much money you have in the bank you
go to the internet and check and say
okay i got a 100 bucks
well
mr putin you know he knocks the
satellite out you go into the internet
and you can't find how much money you
had
and what are you going to tell the bank
i had 100 bucks
yeah they're looking for their money
they're not going to look for yours
okay so yeah
it's all in computer systems try it
through money doesn't grow food try
planning a dollar bill or feeding
livestock uh
coins yeah absolutely so the only reason
we grow and uh
you know grow both livestock and uh
and uh plants you know eatable plants is
because the money
is what triggers us to do it okay so
we're the guys who are doing it because
of money
and but what is money money ultimately
is what does the dollar bill say in god
we trust
uh it's it's all faith that's all it is
that's all that money is
the only reason you receive money is
because you know you feel you predict
whatever you want to call it that you
can
send that dollar bill to someone else
and that person will accept it and give
you whatever you want you want to buy a
house you go with money and you say
here's money and the guy says oh i'll
take that because it has value for me i
believe it has value so he accepts a
hundred two hundred thousand dollars and
he gives you a house or a boat or a car
or whatever
we all understand that
but what if the guy says no i don't want
your money
because it has no
value and you said what do you mean it
has no value
well what are you giving me you're
giving me vietnamese money
you know i i can't do anything with
vietnamese money yeah but money is money
as money is backed by the government of
vietnam
so no money is not money is not money uh
we don't have trust you know the bill in
vietnam i don't think it says in god we
trust it just says in government we
trust and nobody trusts government
so yeah if someone gives you money from
another country you probably won't
accept it depending on what country so
not all money is money okay
and so
that's one issue but the other one is
that you know if the
governments fall apart and you know
suddenly there's no um no value out
there in money itself
because they printed too much of it
salaries are you know so low
you know real value of salaries are so
low that you know they give you money
and it's worthless it's nominal value
you get a million dollars but you can't
buy a bubble gum with it
then you know then at that point people
start losing faith and money and they
say look i'm not going to accept money
anymore now i'm going to accept goods or
food or whatever but they're not going
to accept money when money falls apart
then there's no control okay there's no
control
and you say well that's good because now
we have government off our banks they
can't control us we just exchange with
our neighbors
yeah the problem you can't run a global
economy on bartering not for food which
is what companies produce today
corporations agricultural corporations
and they sell them they you can't go to
them and say look give me a pound of
beans
and i'll give you a dog
you know what am i going to do with the
dog you know we're not in the dog
selling business we can't take the dog
and sell someone else
to buy seed to grow beans so that we can
send you the beans
so we cannot run an economy a global
economy
on um
on bartering
and if the global companies the
corporations that produce and distribute
most of the food on planet earth
don't receive money
you know they can't run their businesses
on bartering you might be able to do
bartering with your neighbor that's not
going to help you at all
with uh with the big corporations that
suddenly you know
will not produce food and will not
distribute food because they're not
getting anything for it aside from the
fact that they laid off all their
employees at that moment okay so there's
a lot of things going on that you cannot
put back together once humpty dumpty
breaks you know you can't put them back
together
so that's in a nutshell you know
uh what you can expect so yeah money
money is just an abstraction okay it's
an abstraction
and that's the worst part because
our very lives depend on that
abstraction on the faith we have in that
abstraction meaning it's it's all faith
and all we have to do is lose lose faith
in money
and not accept that anymore for whatever
reason that's how simple it is to kill
man we don't need bombs we don't need uh
to kill each other
all we need is for money to die and and
that's it and we're done
our very lives depend on that
abstraction on that concept
okay a fella says considering the amish
started with 500
uh 500 and it's now 344 000 and they're
still around i'd say we could still
breed for quite a while if the economy
is intact
yeah
the issue with the amish is that you
know they've been around for 300 plus
years right
and now they're having you know they're
inbreeding and and
they've been in breeding for over 300
years and now uh they're having problems
physical and mental problems there you
have one group who had problems and
there are a lot of doctors that go into
amish towns and they try to study all
the genetic problems that these people
are coming up with and remember the
amish is a microcosm of the world
their inbreeding uh is much faster than
the rest of the world because they've
held a
very tight-knit society okay so within
their society they've been inbreeding
air for about 300 years now 350 years
and yeah now they're starting to have
problems and we're seeing the uh what's
going to happen to humanity as a whole
in that small microcosm okay and so yeah
humanity as a whole has a lot more
inbreeding to do i'm just saying that
we're seeing the tip of the iceberg with
some of the problems we see today and
all the mental problems that you see out
there some of them are due to the fact
that we're in the cities
and
you have this density thing that might
have a might be a factor that you should
consider
but then i think the main one is the
fact that you know we descend from the
same people
that uh
you know that had kids uh 500 years ago
who descended from the people who had
kids
uh 2 000 years ago and so on down the
line so you know what has happened is we
become more and more and more people
but our genetic diversity has
streamlined because those uh parents of
ours who could not pass certain diseases
or did not have children because the war
killed them you know we've been chopping
off diversity and streamlining our
genetic diversity and whatever mutations
we had along that
period of time did not overcome
uh the
you know bottlenecks that we had the
major bottlenecks that we had in
throughout history
okay so that's the theory okay whether
you believe it or not again
uh we're not here to believe we're just
trying to explain theories ex mechanisms
okay
okay uh
says when it comes to sex people are
into all kinds of weird nonsense i think
you're over playing the nature part of
it
uh stuff that people are exposed to and
stuff that happens to them seems like a
better explanation for the sexual
variety okay
uh there must be malleability to
sexuality some people get off to shoes
issue you know and that's just more
humorous mundane
example uh explain the genetic defect
could possibly make a person get a
hard-on for a shoe
okay so this is the issue the issue is
um
we can have sex with anything but we
cannot produce children with anything we
can only produce children with other
humans okay i mean if you want to have
sex with an ant go ahead and have it
and good luck there okay
uh does that mean that if you have sex
with a shoe you're gonna get a cobbler
okay so so it's it's not like you know
that you can have sex with anything you
can have sex with anyone you want but
the issue is
you know some people do it with animals
out there dogs and cows and so on
donkeys the question is whether
having sex with such an animal will
produce
a children offspring
we're talking about offspring here
that's what the bottom line is we're
saying that humans are not producing
children okay so sex is one thing that's
you know pleasure whatever you have sex
with is irrelevant okay
and again uh the issue with neanderthals
was whether we had sex with them as the
geneticists say because we have two
percent commonality in our genetic code
with them um
yeah sure
here's this ape
arctic eight and we went there we had
sex with them
uh i wonder how they
communicated and the other guy didn't
understand he was just hunting and he
said i need you as my supper today
that's the way it was
okay uh here's another house says check
out uh pasture and b champ or bashamp uh
a column b champ this pure germ theory
was uh dispute germ theory was debunked
a century ago
and yeah there's you have the two
fighters okay and one came french guys
both and one came up with the germ
theory and the other one with terrain
theory uh
and again with all this cobit a lot of
people are looking into these things uh
terrain theory essentially you know
without going into too much detail
because i'm not really into this at all
but
terrain theory says that for example
i'll just give you an example to
illustrate it
if you are sick or you are weak or you
don't have the right genes
right
then there's greater chance of the bug
entering you know a virus or bacteria
doing harm to your body okay because the
body is weak
and that to some degree i guess is true
because as you get older you know we
cannot avoid getting old and as you get
older you have fewer defenses against
normal bugs okay so it's it's uh very
likely that this terrain theory has some
uh level of truth some measure of truth
a lot of people believe in this saying
hey if you stay healthy if you do your
exercise if you eat well or you don't
eat garbage and so on well you'll have
better defenses against the germs and
the germ guys say well no matter what
you do you know if you get this bug go
into your cell just break in there or
the cell sucks it in
it makes copies of itself and uh you
know and makes you sick because it makes
uh inside the cell it makes copies of
itself the virus or the
bacteria
and it uses cell material to do so
so i think they both have a
some measure of truth at least that's my
take on that
um uh
what can i say you know that's my my
overall feel for what these
two
um tendencies
in uh or these two theories these two
generic theories are all about german
versus terrain
uh i think they both have some measure
of truth the one that has triumphed was
pastures by the way and that's the one
that a lot of people in these days don't
accept because that's followed up with
injections right with vaccines and
people say oh i don't like that theory
well the theory could be you know maybe
it's right you know maybe it's a it's a
rational theory
that you know the bugs enter the cell
the question is did they enter the cell
because the cell kind of drew them in by
mistake or whatever or is it that
the cell is weak and it doesn't
understand or lost its bearings and
somehow sucks the virus in
by mistake because it is weak whereas a
guy who's got a very strong cell maybe
won't
you know suck that uh virus in
so that's you know is the glass half
empty or half full more or less
situation
okay final issue on extinction here we
go uh fella says learn the other
day that three meter gap today
uh apparently there is a lack of
dinosaur bones before the asteroid layer
you'd think something like that would be
more uh prominent unless there was a
narrative to protect okay
uh yeah there is a lot of uh protection
of theories out there especially by the
establishment and so they don't like to
have new theories come in there because
this is what they grew up on this is
what they learned in college and one
generation you know just borrowed from
the previous one
and so uh they just keep repeating the
same thing you get a phd on the same
thing and then now you're up there in
the high places and someone says your
theory is wrong it's irrational whatever
the guy goes you know bonkers he says no
way
you know i got this from dr so-and-so
and we've had 20 years or 30 or 40 years
of this theory and so yeah there's
there's a big problem with this and um
yeah all he's saying is that
there's this theory that says that uh
or or criticism really of the theory
saying
you know they found out that if you go
below the rock layer where the asteroid
struck
well
you already find that the dinosaurs were
already gone
so the asteroid
had nothing to do with the extinction of
the dinosaurs that's the
that's the conclusion right
and
here you look it up i found an article
bbc okay this dates to july 2011
and it says closing the three meter gap
okay
you can look it up okay and uh what do
they say well what they essentially say
is they got this from an article
uh published by a group okay and this is
what this group says it says dinosaur
extinction closing the three meter gap
that's where they got this from the bbc
okay
and these folks argue that again that
you know the dinosaurs were already gone
by the time the um the asteroid hit
and again this dates to 2011 remember
the asteroid
theory the mechanism
at least dates to albert to alvarez
louise alvarez's
paper 1980 that uh you know kind of
reinforced the notion that already was
around
in fact that notion that some
extraterrestrial impact
killed some of the animals in the past
especially the dinosaurs dates all the
way
all the way to
mr george kubier in those days the
french already thought about the fact
that it could be that could have been an
extraterrestrial impact
and so uh you know when you look at that
you say well this theory has been around
for 200 years so what did the alvarez
him and his son what did they come up
with well what they said they came up
with what is important to the
mathematicians proof
evidence
they say oh we found the evidence oh
what's the evidence well there's this
layer of iridium that covers the earth
and that could have only been brought uh
at that
point in time you know throughout the
earth it could have been brought only by
an asteroid that hit the earth
and that covered the land with you know
with this uh
uh iridium
and so
they concluded from that that that was
the proof the evidence they were looking
for to prove
the theory that an asteroid is what
killed the
the dinosaurs
what uh the alvarez and no one else in
paleontology has been able to prove
is um
how it is that that asteroid was so
smart
that it could distinguish
chronologically
how it was that it killed the old
species the dinosaurs
and the uh stuff they ate which were all
the conifers
and left alive not only the
mammals which are
what we are you know the new species
that
governs the planet today
but also what they eat which are the
angiosperms
so uh the gymnosperms they disappeared
together with the dinosaurs and what was
left
were the mammals that radiated after the
big guys were gone
and the foods they ate which were all
the angiosperms
now how smart can a asteroid be
okay so until you can prove
that okay
[Music]
i cannot tell you what i think of your
asteroid theory okay
okay let's move on to
physics okay
physics per se okay let's go in there
and we had a couple people who are still
moving concepts around they still don't
understand physics they want to do
some measure of religion it's not even
religion it's irrationality
because religion you know i say
supernatural
mechanisms
you know they're they're to some degree
irrational but at least you have
a the objects are there
why because you say well god let us
assume that there is god
well what is god well god is this guy
with a magic wand
okay
let's concede that at least you can
imagine god you know a guy with a beard
not a little longer than mine probably
and magic wands waving and saying
abracadabra and he creates the universe
or whatever he creates plants he can
create anything he wants
okay
the mechanism is a little supernatural
but we can imagine god at least
what are you going to imagine for
four-dimensional space-time
what are you going to imagine for a
particle being at two places at once
and even worse
how can you imagine
transferring you know waves or energy
shaking the field
these are all concepts
and so that's
irrational
irrational means you're going to be
moving concepts around
and that's different than supernatural
will says well the objects are there
now you don't believe that god exists
that there is a god out there that's
fine you don't believe in my theory but
i've got an object and this object has a
magic wand waves it around creates
things
so the mechanism a little is a little
magical but at least the object is there
but mathematical physics doesn't even
have objects you can't even start the
presentation because there's nothing to
begin with
you cannot explain a mechanism with
concepts you need objects so as a
minimum you know at least you gotta
introduce god or the angels or some kind
of object there
and mathematical physics doesn't have
that it just has concepts and so these
two fellas apparently were educated at
the same monastery monastery uh that
teaches you know the movement of
concepts and that's what they say say
look at the beams of light from a source
a ball of light is made of beams made of
beans beam is a concept there's no
physical object called beam but if you
know a physical object called beam bring
it to the conference room just a beam i
don't want anything else i don't want
what created the beam i want you to
bring the beam put it on the table and
say this is a beam
is there such a thing
and the beams are center of left and
right moving
magnetospheres magnetospheres what's a
magnetosphere never seen that object
just bring it in again put it on the
table so we know what you're talking
about and he's saying only vortices
well vortis is just a tornado tornado is
not a physical object
air is a physical object you know you
can say air is made out of atoms it's
standalone that's standing still you
don't have to move air to conceptualize
air just a bunch of atoms
you take a snapshot of that if you could
color code them you've got air okay if
you can see them if you got god's camera
so you would take a picture of all these
uh atoms
and that whole blob we call air that's a
physical object it's got shape the whole
blob has shape just like a chair has a
shape chair is made out of countless
atoms just like any gas
and so gases are objects and you know
furnitures are objects trees are objects
rocks are objects
is a rock made of a gazillion
number of atoms of course so is so is
gas
okay so all these are objects
but tornado tornado does never stops
moving until it stops
moving we don't have an object because
object is a static concept
and so that thing would have to stand
still in order for us to identify what
the object is
now that thing stands still well all we
have is an ice cream cone
okay we don't have a
tornado tornado is something that's
moving by definition it's got to twirl
around that's what a board is is
vortex is is you know something that's
moving around you got to identify that
something
so yeah this fellow doesn't understand
that he's uh
not very uh
much into physics
okay
now a fellow along the same line says
the average human at
rest produces around 100 watts of power
okay
at death the body stops generating
electricity
no more power
okay so
he says that's like an analogy for what
happens to a battery a charged battery
has more mass than it does this charge
so i guess when the battery dies the
spirit
flies away and you can measure and weigh
the spirit and say oh the spirit of the
battery was a physical object it went to
heaven
hopefully you haven't met the hell right
okay uh
yeah it just shows that all these people
are doing concepts
okay you can't talk about charge you
can't talk about
what is it
mass or electricity those are not
physical objects physical object is that
which you can bring to the table and put
it in front of all of us you know uh you
don't have to bring the real thing you
can bring a drawing of it
an illustration an image
whatever no problem but you got to bring
something that we can see and touch like
they say right
they want see and touch there's your
chance to see and touch it okay bring it
in show us what you have in your mind
okay inside the brain and uh yeah for
that we need to see the shape you don't
have to draw it in front of us you don't
have to
you know say oh i need to draw it fine
finish the drawing then bring it in we
just want to see the shape
okay if if it has shave it has shape
even if i die that whatever you showed
has shape already before i even look at
it okay so whatever you bring like if
you bring a tree
tree already has shape before i come
into the room okay when i come into a
room i see a shape and i say oh okay the
uh something that has shape
okay and that's what you got to do with
all these
concepts such as electricity which is a
dynamic concept okay no physical
standalone object called electricity
vortex no stand-alone object called
vortex and none of these uh charge
field all the words of mathematical
physics all their you know famous words
none of them are physical objects that's
why it's an irrational
discipline
because all the words are concepts and
they're treated as physical objects
that's the issue
okay and
so you say well do we need to see this
see because we we've already figured out
we already figured out
all the visible stuff
you you uh you see a donkey pull a cart
and you ask well how did the cart end up
over there
very simple you say the donkey pulled on
the cart because it was attached to the
carton and pulled it over there
we all understand it just by looking at
the the movie we say well how did the
cart get over there we know the donkey
pulled it because everything is visible
it's the invisible stuff we have
problems with the mathematicians have
trouble with why because they never
define the word object and they don't do
their physics with objects they never
simulate with objects they use concepts
they say oh the field oh the energy
mass
force time
oh there's a concept you can't do a
physical mechanism with that
and see when when they talk about the
donkey pulling a card everybody said
well that's clear you know the donkey
pulled on the card baby stuff everybody
can understand it
but you know what if you couldn't see
some of these invisible things which is
the problem that mathematicians have
they don't see the invisible mediators
and that's when they all go bonkers
they say oh how did that happen
and and here you have a situation let me
show you
hey here you have
a box being pulled up
and you say how is that box being pulled
up it's magic
you know you don't see the mediator
that's the whole issue
and so you ponder and you say what was
the force or the energy that pushed it
from below push the mass from below the
force that it applied to the box and you
use all these concepts but you can't say
that a force push that an energy pulled
you can't say that the mass did this or
anything like that what you have to
explain is how did the box come up
because the only objects that you see
there are the visible objects the ones
we can illustrate okay
and so you know you could see what's
going on like for example here okay now
you say oh okay i understand how the box
came up there was a rope tied to it
that's how the box came up
okay so now you can explain it because
all you have to do is illustrate it
really and you can see why the box came
up everybody can understand that without
any
you know magical stuff
it's this that the mathematicians cannot
explain that's the one they cannot
explain
and they and that's when they start
using all these fancy words that they've
created like energy and field and mass
because they have no other way to relate
to it and all those only tell us how
fast that thing moves how much it weighs
it doesn't tell us anything about the
mechanism of how the box came up and
that's the problem we have today with
mathematical physics you ask them how is
it that the earth
remains faithful to the sun why does it
fly out of the solar system
i mean what's holding it there
and so they say well we have space time
well speech time is a concept time is a
concept so space time hopefully is a
concept
and they say what's on your mansion four
dimensional
no you're talking about concepts all all
concepts are unimaginable because you
cannot imagine because there's nothing
to visualize
so you can't say that time mixed with
space is a mechanism that prevents the
earth from flying out of the solar
system that's the issue
and so that's where we run into trouble
okay you have to explain the mechanism
and hopefully all mechanisms are
mediated by objects
for else you are doing your explanation
your theory your physical interpretation
with black magic
you're saying there's nothing there
between the earth and the sun
but the earth doesn't fly away and it
always goes around in the same circle
more or less right always around and
around doesn't fly out
we've calculated how fast we know how
much a second is how much a year is we
know the speed the mass we know all that
stuff
we've calculated all that we've measured
it great
we still cannot not a single
mathematician on planet earth can tell
you why that earth doesn't fly out of
the solar system
and the only way you're going to explain
it is just like we had to explain it
with the
pulley
you got to make the invisible visible
you got to make that rope
visible then you know how that box came
up as long as you don't make that rope
visible you're going to be talking about
energy and mass and field and force and
other nonsense that has nothing to do
with the mechanism of why the box came
up
so that's the difference between physics
and mathematics okay what all these
people do is mathematics
okay um
so here we have um
in order to get to the subject matter
today which is resistance resistors okay
we need to really
go into electricity we need to
understand what electricity is and
that's where the mathematicians have had
problems all these years both classical
as well as
mathematicians uh mathematical physicist
right as they call themselves and also
the dissonance you know people like the
electric universe and
the
john chappelle
group there all these groups they've
never defined
electricity they don't know what
electricity is
and part of the reason there is they
keep doing uh their physics or their
electricity their charges their
voltages
and resistors and so on they do it all
with concepts
and not only do they do it with concepts
but even worse they're using the uh
planetary model of the atom
and before they can use that they have
to justify where the electron bead just
like the earth from the sun doesn't fly
away
why does the electron bead stay within
what is known as an orbital or an energy
level or whatever whatever they want to
call that concept what does it say in
that region why does it fly away or fall
to the nucleus i mean whichever
and so they've got they already have
problems starting okay so this is the
issue so let's understand let's see how
much we can understand about electricity
okay
and here is well one file who says how
fast does electricity travel and this is
good because it's not one thought it's a
company by the way okay and so it's
important to know uh from this what
notions the mathematical physicists have
of what electricity is
and
this comes in a way because you know
they're trying to figure out how
electricity moves in that wire okay when
you have electricity you have a power
supply and you know you have these uh
wires coming out of it and it turns out
that you can turn on a light bulb so
they have to explain that and so this is
the explanation they have today it's got
to do a little bit or quite a bit
actually with the speed of electricity
says electricity is the flow of
electrons through a conductor in an
electric field so what is electricity
the flow of electrons through
okay
let's repeat that it's the flow of
electrons through something okay this
energy travels now that's energy that's
traveling we have this concept called
energy it's going to travel
and how is it going to travel as an
electromagnetic wave
so we have uh now this wave which is a
concept
dynamic concept it's a motion of
something that's waving that's
undulating and it's going to be energy
that travels as a wave
so we already have a big problem there
because these explanations are using not
objects but they're using abstract
concepts we can't use the word energy or
the word wave in physics you gotta
identify what is waving you have to
identify what this energy thingy is
okay and so they say the energy the
waves they travel about the speed of
light okay however the electrons
themselves within the waves
move more slowly
in fact as we've seen in the past a
couple
lectures ago
electrons barely move at all
some of them never make it to the end of
the line to the um to the positive pole
meaning that electrons are negative
they're supposed to be attracted to the
positive pole some of them never make it
because they move very slowly within
this so-called wave within this energy
this field that is traveling so what is
traveling according to them is a concept
called wave energy or field but the
electron balls the beads themselves they
move much more slowly in fact they they
talk about moving
millimeters
moving net at all we're not talking
about the speed of light here we're
talking about something that moves from
here to there like an ant that's what
they're saying
okay so let's keep going here it says
what is the speed of electrons in
electricity okay when the free electrons
bounce around they create an electric
charge okay whatever charge is there's
no physical object called charge so you
can't create a charge whatever that is
with electrons okay what are we building
a mountain of some kind of electrons is
that what it is no charge is a
mathematical concept it's a value so
they're talking about numbers they're
not talking about things
talking about concepts
since electrons are negatively charged
whatever negatively means because we
don't know what negative is had a bad
day and so they're negative
is that what it is i mean what is
negative in physical terms
since they're negatively charged they
are propelled to the opposite direction
of the positive charge whatever positive
is you know again you know what is what
is this negative and positive these are
just saying they could have said a and z
or a and b or whatever
you know x and y
east and west they went from east to
west so what does that mean why did they
go to eastern or to from east to west
that's what you got to explain what's
physically happening and so they say
energetic bouncing creates an electric
charge again that word charge that's
where an electrical force to move the
electrons in one direction comes in aha
so we have a force now now we have
another big word we have this force
whatever that is you know electrical
force i hope it's it's a like a wall or
a paddle is that what electrical force
is what's the physical object that's
what we want to know don't tell me
there's a force okay that may the force
go with you
electrical currents can be compared to
the flow of water in a pipe
aha flow of water in the pipe what are
they talking about well they're talking
about something like this we showed this
in the past okay where you have
particles flowing downhill okay
and you can have positive to negative or
negative to positive it really doesn't
matter because they say that electricity
essentially goes both ways the positive
ones move in one direction
uh in semiconductor they're known as
holes
and negative ones moving the opposite
direction what have we learned nothing
okay and they say it's like this they
say it's uh some kind of water flow
and there's this potential
high level to a low level i guess you
know because that's how they always
illustrate it
and then the question is are we talking
about pressure pushing the electrons
forward the electron beads forward are
we talking about more electrons what are
we talking about here what is this uh
what is this flow okay so that's what we
want to understand and why is it
happening what is this voltage that's
happening in there right
and so the more pressure at one end the
stronger the flow of water or
electricity again they're not explaining
what is changing is it the more that we
have more electrons more water or are we
saying there's more pressure from from
one of the ends
is are we saying that one of the uh
terminals is higher than the other one
is that the potential that they're
talking about
okay so these are the questions that we
have to ask if we're going to understand
this physically okay
while the speed of the transmission of
the electrical current itself is about
the speed of light the actual electrons
within that wave might only move along
what a few millimeters per second
okay so we're talking about something
very slow we're talking about an amp
moving within some kind of wave or field
or energy whatever that thing and that's
going at the speed of light is but the
electrons themselves they're moving very
little this is what these people are
saying so on the one hand they say look
electricity is the flow of electrons but
then they say the electrons barely move
and you say well if they barely move how
is it they make it all the way to the
other side and turn the lamp on
so so it's not the flow of electrons
something else is flowing and they call
that
something a nothing it's a concept it's
energy or field or wave or something
like that okay the the electrons are not
moving they're moving very little
it says this is because the electrons
themselves are bouncing around the
conductance creating the energy creating
energy what is energy no physical object
called the energy okay
that is released in the way what is a
wave no such monster is a wave but are
necessarily moving along with it so the
electrons are moving with it they're
moving very little but something is
speeding at the speed of light which is
this energy this uh charge this whatever
it is that concept that they're talking
about that that's what's moving all the
way to the end of the line
okay in the case of an alternating
current and here you see
how it comes falls apart okay an
alternating current where the current
changes direction 50 or 60 times per
second most of the electrons never make
it out of the wire
but electricity itself is still flowing
thanks to the electrons excitement
okay a lot of excitement but
no explanation okay so we have no idea
under mathematical physics what
electricity is is electricity the flow
of electrons or not it's a yes or no
question
so if the electrons are moving we can
say okay the electrons move they went to
this atom and it turned the light on or
did this effect whatever it is
but if the electrons are not moving
they're moving very little there's just
a bunch of indians moving around okay
then the question is what is traveling
what is it that is speeding at the speed
of light and they're saying it's the
energy it's the field it's the charge
they're talking about mathematical
concepts that's what they're saying is
speeding that's what's traveling at the
speed of light electrons themselves
they move very little they move like
little ants that's all it is meaning
under the rope model you know you have
in-situ torsions that we can understand
because that explains why light is so
fast on the one hand right why the
signal reaches the other end very
quickly because if you have a serpentine
that's turning on itself you have a
snake that turns on itself let's say you
have a circular snake you know head the
head tied to its tail you turn it around
the whole thing turns at the same time
so you can understand why now the signal
so-called signal energy charge whatever
you want to call it
you know why it has an instantaneous
effect almost okay because it twirls and
sits you but if you have these little
ants carrying
charge or energy or field or whatever on
on their backs
you know how does it deliver it well
they say they don't because the energy
travels faster than the ant
so you figure it out what they're trying
to say i mean they should illustrate
this that'd be great because if they
could illustrate what they're saying be
absolutely great
and of course you're never going to be
able to illustrate energy you're not
going to be able to illustrate field
wave
okay what are you going to illustrate
for a wave a two fields
uh
what is it the
orthogonal fields
traveling uh
transversally to both of them
what is that you know what are you going
to illustrate vectors
okay so this is the issue they don't
have they cannot illustrate their
theories and all physical theories
mechanisms
should be illustrate to bold okay okay
uh so
here we have uh voltage you know here's
the definition essentially you said
voltage is a potential difference or
electric pressure is the difference in
electric potential between two points in
other words they have a high point and a
low point
and so all we know about voltage is not
what the physical mechanism is all we
know is that one is high and the other
one is low one is positive the other one
is negative whatever all those words
mean yeah what does that have to do with
physics we need to know why one is why
high and the other one low is one higher
than the other one one is on a mountain
the other one's on a valley is that what
it is what do they mean high potential
low potential what is that those are
just numbers
voltage is defined so that negatively
charged objects are pulled towards the
higher voltages
yeah but tell me why it's being pulled
to the high voltage don't tell me it is
tell me why it is what's causing it to
go in that direction
while positively charged objects are
pulled towards the lower voltages great
we learned a lot we learned that you
guys don't know anything
we learned that the mathematicians have
never figured out what electricity is
what voltage is and as we will see they
haven't figured out because of that what
resistance is what a resistor is
okay um
continuing here
uh here's
essentially their mechanism they're
saying that electricity is just a flow
of electron beads okay they're moving
from atom to atom in one direction
uh
they're moving very slowly because
what's actually going through some kind
of
abstract concept known as energy or
field or charge or whatever okay
electricity uh no there it is uh this is
their mechanism they're saying the
electron beads are moving from atom to
atom what is pushing each one of these
electron beads we don't know why are
they moving from atom to atom what is
compelling them to leave
you know the valence band or
and move into the conduction band of of
an atom why are the electrons being
pushed out of there i mean if if this is
a single little um
bead
and it's um orbiting the atom somehow
you know or somewhere
within the orbitals or
energy levels what is compelling that
electron to leave its atom and start
flowing
that's what they have to explain without
that we have absolutely nothing we don't
have a mechanism
okay
and uh this is uh
you can see they're going more or less
slowly let's speed it up and i guess
to speed them up you have to increase
the potential okay so let's increase the
potential okay there it is okay now
they're going a little faster
why because they're rolling downhill
okay and so now we have a little uh a
bigger angle we have a
greater incline plane
okay
and let's even speed it up a little more
see if we can get it to go faster the
electricity okay there we go
now we have faster electricity okay
right what are we saying are we having
more electrons falling down uh more
water or is it that
they're going faster are the electrons
going faster because now we have a
greater potential
what are we talking about in other words
this is where these people have to
explain this in detail they can't just
say it does this it does so okay
and they have to explain the mechanism
what is causing the electrons to flow
are we talking about more electrons are
we talking about more charges
uh more electricity what does that mean
more river flowing is it because there's
more pressure and if there's more
pressure are we saying that we have more
electrons flowing
or are we talking about uh
the fact that um
you know the electrons are going faster
because you know you can make a river
run a little faster
you just apply more pressure and the
river goes faster is that what's
happening uh with electricity more
there's faster electricity and lower
slower electricity
uh
you know movement of electrons
and they say well the electrons move so
and so but that's got nothing to do with
the signal that reaches at the other end
well signal is a concept i need to know
what physical object came at the other
end
because when you talk about when you use
the analogy of water we can say oh we
have more water at the other end we can
all understand that we have more water
either because there's more pressure
more water ran through or the water ran
faster or any of those things
i want the analogy that same analogy to
be used on electron flow
what do we get at the other end more
electrons
okay
more water uh
faster water
faster electrons electricity flows
faster here than over there
now this is what we need to resolve with
the uh
quantum version of and
even the
classical one right but this is the
issue with mathematical physics these
are the questions you have to ask a
mathematician okay and here they are
okay all three of them put together okay
i guess if the
potential
if the wire if you if you hold the wire
a little
at a bigger angle right and the other
one is almost 180 degrees or zero
degrees i guess the electron flow slower
than if you put them on a higher
potential
[Laughter]
so this is what they got to answer they
got to illustrate what i illustrated
there if they're going to talk about
potential and they're going to say well
the analogy is the water flow like you
know water coming uh
down a pipe great no problem
uh just uh illustrated now for electrons
what are we talking about more electrons
faster electrons
okay this is what you gotta explain
okay so um
yeah what does the uh
resistor look like for
because you know now we're now we're
going to put a stop to the
to the flow somehow we're going to
interrupt the flow some we're going to
put a dam
to the river on the river okay and i've
illustrated it there you saw it there in
the
icon i used for this video and yeah you
have the vikings you know they're
attacking the fort and you have the poor
people there trying to defend themselves
it turns out the vikings will go through
because they're much more numerous
tougher or whatever but they don't
annihilate every one of the uh
you know defenders
and part of that is because you know uh
if they did then you would have an
avalanche is known as electricity
electronics uh you have you know
breakthrough voltage
what they call okay
so yeah uh this is more or less their
notion you have all these
electrons because that's how they always
explain it until you put them against
the wall and they say well it's not the
electrons that are flowing what's really
flowing is the energy
what's flowing is the field
the wave the charge
electricity
the electricity is the
flowing of beads and you have the
flowing or flowing of beads
because you have flowing electricity
electricity flows what do you mean by
that what means that if electricity is
the flowing of beads you have flowing of
beads is flowing
the flowing or flowing that's what
electricity is according to all these
people that's that's their notion that's
their definition that's what it comes
down to when you analyze what they're
saying okay
okay uh
here you have a
difference um between
a resistor and a conductor okay because
uh not only conductor but also the
insulator
uh
all you have is uh different degrees of
dams in the river
uh some material you know uh
resist
electricity the flow of electrons i
guess more than others okay so you put
this dam in there called the resistor
and it's gonna
block the river a little more than the
another one okay so you do that to be
able to control
this whatever electricity is right
and fellow said this is again a company
okay it says conductors allow
electricity to flow and insulators to
stop electricity
insulators don't really stop electricity
altogether they say
you're going to see that but they say
you know if you have an insulator and
it's quite wide and quite thick it's a
big dam it blocks the river all together
that's more or less their notion and
again what are they blocking electron
flow
okay so keep that in mind they're
blocking electrons and you say well why
can't the energy continue flowing
i mean i need to reach i need for the
energy to reach the opposite pole what's
stopping the energy what's stopping the
concept what's stopping the wave what's
stopping the field what's topping the
charge i thought all these were concepts
why would i mean you can say that the
wall the dam stops the electron bead
that we we can understand if the
electron beat is a little ball okay
what's stopping the energy from flowing
for that you would need to figure out
what energy is and what physical object
can stop this concept
you know this is the issue well that's
rather simplified view he says you know
um
because
it says for example air is normally an
insulator okay but with a large enough
voltage it becomes a conductor
okay keep that in mind
we have a circuit here
and we have air air is an insulator but
if you increase the voltage whatever
voltage is the potential you know one
higher the other one lower i guess i
don't know if you're going to use the
river analogy then
or the pipe analogy water going through
a pipe then you have to think of it in
these terms okay they're saying that if
if the
potential
is great enough
the
beads will go through the pipe anyways
or the river will go right through the
dam anyways
okay that's what they're saying okay
it's just a question of potential how
much potential how much uh pressure
uh you apply and the pressure is of is a
function
of
the potential
and potential according to their analogy
is
one higher and the other one lower it's
the water flow the river flow the
water going through a pipe okay so keep
all this in mind because that's the
analogy they're going to use 99 of
people explain it with this water flow
you know voltage they explain with this
water flow thing analogy
and so it says
for example you know air is normally an
insulator but with large enough voltage
it becomes a conductor as we uh see when
lightning forms in an electrical storm
and again
they don't know why they just say it
does so
but they cannot explain why why that
happens okay so really the air is
resistant to the flow of electricity and
this is how we get to the idea of
electrical resistance okay let's see
what ideas are taking us to a conductor
can be better explained as having a low
resistance and an insulator as having
high resistance
so they all
have
resistance they're all conductors to
some degree but it's a question of how
high it's a question of degrees that's
what this fellow is saying or these this
company is saying it's a question of
degrees
and here you see it okay
here's a
illustration of that okay you have an
insulator has a resistance much higher
than resistors so large that no useful
current flows when a voltage is applied
okay and there you have different
materials and they have different
resistance values insulating values
conducting values okay
and so you get rubber at one end you get
silver on the other end great
so you're saying that silver is very
conductive and rubber is not
okay
and so these are some of the materials
of which resistors are made okay what do
they make them off well you see there
you have the resist uh resistive wire
okay the wire resistor okay nickel
chromium alloy okay so they put a nickel
chromium alloy the core is ceramic or
fiberglass and that it creates some kind
of impedance or some kind of resistance
uh carbon fine carbon particles and
non-conductive ceramic material that's
what they use as materials okay now you
see others metal film nichrome uh
tantalum uh nitride metal oxide they use
tin oxide and then they have the foil
which is metal full cemented on a
ceramic substrate
those are the materials okay so why are
those material what do they do
that's what we i mean we're gonna know
how they do it
okay so great you got the materials you
got a description
you know it's like uh
edison
edison had no idea whatsoever what he
was doing
uh edison was just trying one thing
after another until he got it right
again a very perfect example of how
technology is developed by trial and
error
or like uh tesla said of
of edison if uh
they were enemies at the end of their
lives but uh tesla said you know if um
edison had to
uh find a needle in a haystack he would
go one straw at a time until he found
the needle he says there are better ways
than that to do it he suggested you know
doing calculations and so on but yeah
edison just was a guy a workaholic he
did a lot of work and that's good that's
that's a virtue but he was a businessman
he was not a
scientist under no circumstance
okay
so here we have uh the circus that we
have today from the establishment
and one guy asked the other day it says
why do we have to close the circuit
which is a good question i mean why do
we have to close the circuit if
you know we have uh what insulator there
air
so between the two terminals positive
and negative where we close the switch
in dc right
uh
let's assume there's air
why do we have to close the circuit and
create this conductor why don't we just
increase the uh
power
the potential
and send those electrons right through
the through the air to the other side
you know you don't have to go through
the bridge you jump from one
bank
of the river to the other bank
in one shot because you're thrown with
enough force you know maybe a cannonball
uh cannon
ball man you know goes into the cannon
you shoot him he crosses the river
he doesn't need a bridge so why do you
need a brick
and there you have it with the ac the
alternate current
uh you can see that the electrons never
make it either side they just go back
and forth but somehow
the energy or the field or the whatever
is this ghost this this uh spirit is
what reaches the terminals
we want to know what that spirit is
because that spirit has an effect it's a
spirit that turns the light on or
whatever you're you're powering right so
we want to know what that spirit is
because that's the one that goes at the
speed of light that's when it's going to
turn your light on constantly right
because if we rely on the poor little
electron that's moving one millimeter
per second you know it will never make
it
so forget about the electrons here we
have to explain
what these energy these fields are
that's what we have to explain or draw
them and really illustrate them so that
we can understand the mechanism okay so
this is the issue
okay uh here we go uh classical versus
uh quantum okay because something has
changed
and that is that under classical
mechanics or really a transition from
classical to
to uh quantum okay
what happened was you know in classical
mechanics they essentially thought there
were atoms there and you had the they
found the electrons
1897 you know uh
and
what happened they they said okay so we
have these electron beads and that's
probably we're going to call them
negative arbitrarily we don't know what
they what negative means but these
electron beads are moving from atom to
adam that was a notion that was starting
at the beginning of the century 19 20th
century
and quantum took that all that away
they took the atom away
what happens now they say that
electricity is just a flow of beads
and again the beads move very slowly but
you don't need atoms you can have a
vacuum chamber like you see there and
they're saying that the electrons are
moving through the vacuum
scary stuff
because they're saying now we don't need
the atom now the electron is not moving
from atom to atom to atom
now the electron is going right through
from
uh
cathode to anode
i hope you understood what i just said
we don't need the atom anymore you can
vacuum the chamber according to these
people you can vacuum the chamber
and you can have electrons flow
from one plate to another
and so we don't need the atom anymore so
forget about this electricity where you
have the electron beam moving from atom
to atom right now they've got rid of the
atom now we have just flow of electrons
that's the notion of quantum mechanics
and so now they're going to do physics
with this and it's all magic it's all
done with a magic wand because we don't
know what's moving each one of those
electrons
we need to know what physical object
came in contact with the electron before
it starts to move why they're all moving
what are you going to use force energy
mass
what physical object are you going to
use to move the electron
and now you don't even need to move them
from atom to atom they just flow for
whatever reason we have no idea why they
flow
uh what's causing them to flow
we don't even know what the atom looks
like before they flow why they
get stuck to the atom to the nucleus of
the atom okay while they're so
faithful to the nucleus of the atom why
they don't spontaneously just fly away
why do you need to
uh exert some kind of pressure or
something to get them to move it should
be pressure i would assume right i don't
think they're talking about pool i think
they're talking about push right
okay um
here we have another illustration and
this is what we showed before okay we
have all these electrons going from atom
to atom but now we're going to modify
that according to quantum mechanics and
or the notion they have of what a
circuit is and we're going to get rid of
a couple of those atoms and we're just
going to have those electrons flowing
from
through the air okay so so right now
they're going through
the um
what is it through through uh the
insulator which in this case is air okay
so the atoms are just moving
and so this is this is their notion
today that you can that if you apply
enough force
uh potential
voltage whatever you want to call it uh
once you apply that well then the
electrons are going to flow through the
air right through the uh insulator in
this case right the material that's
serving or supposed to serve as a dam
okay just go they just go right through
the dam
okay
okay
here we have
again all these different
uh
potentials
and the question is
that you should ask yourself is do they
go faster are there more electrons i
mean what's the issue here the fact that
you have more potential meaning i guess
you know one higher than the other one
whatever potential is i can only
illustrate it like this because this is
how they illustrate the water
analogy so i have to assume this is what
they've got in mind if they have
something else in mind they should use a
different analogy they should not use
the water analogy
because maybe it's completely misleading
okay so that's my point and so the
question is if you have more potential
still the question remains do the
electrons flow faster
or is it that the energy moves faster i
mean what's moving i i need to know what
are we talking about more electrons
these are questions that are basic in in
physics
that you must answer okay otherwise you
have no mechanism for how electricity
works okay
okay uh here's the rope model okay just
in case
we started out the other day and to
explain what voltage is and we're saying
that uh and again this is very basic so
that we try to explain give you an idea
what voltage is so that you can build
upon this okay we're saying we have a
bath this is the typical lead battery
and you have a bath of
sulfuric
acid
in water and so what you have there is
that the
molecules
of lead and lead dioxide move relatively
slowly
they're being
they're being attacked by this acid okay
and so there is a reaction but the
reaction is very slow
and the way you get this to go much
faster is by tying a wire around and now
these things move a lot faster
and what we're saying is what's
happening here is you have all these
electron uh shells because under the
rope model this these are shells they're
balloons
and they're merged one with another
uh physically and so what happens is on
one side you have clockwise on the other
side you have counterclockwise okay so
that's voltage okay it's just this
positive negative is really
uh
clockwise and counterclockwise mother
nature does not understand positive
negative mother nature only understands
you know clockwise and counterclockwise
okay that she does understand okay so
this gives you an idea of what we think
of as far as voltage is concerned
what is current okay and here's the we
got to look at that as well before we
get to the resistor
and this is current okay so if
if a cathode is attached to an anode
there had better be atoms in between
if we could produce absolute
uh vacuum there
you would not have electricity flowing
okay now i worked in the industry uh 15
years in semiconductor industry and i
can tell you one thing is that when you
uh vacuum a chamber
to below
five to uh what is it uh
to the minus uh seven torr
which is very high vacuum
you don't get any current flowing maybe
some arcing here and there meaning
sometimes you get a lightning bolt but
you know you don't get any current
if you could take this
to -12
like you have maybe on the moon or in
the uh
what is in the solar wind
you wouldn't get any current there you
don't get current you don't get a
constant current okay it's impossible
and these people are saying you get a
constant current as long as you have
enough voltage
and i'm saying no you can't send
electrons through the air because that's
not what electricity is electricity is
the
torquing of atoms which are in molecules
right that are bound to each other
physically so
once you remove the atoms you will not
have any electricity flowing you won't
even have what is known as a plasma
which is an ionization
because you don't have any atoms to
ionize among other things
okay so you can't remove all the
material from a chamber and expect to
have the electrons from one
like from the cathode jump all the way
to the anode because there's no bridge
you do need a bridge a physical bridge
otherwise again you're doing
this physical interpretation with
concepts with abstract you're doing it
with black magic okay more than black
magic because if anyone can
turn a uh
a concept into a physical object man
that's not even god can do that
okay so uh here you have uh
comparison of electricity of quantum
mechanics or classical mechanics either
one it doesn't matter where they have
the electron beads rolling around they
say it doesn't they say it does we don't
know if if this should be taken
literally or not uh are the electron
bees flowing all around which is what
they teach in high school then in
college they when you get there they say
well it's not really that they go around
they move very little what moves around
is the energy
or the electricity or whatever they say
you know the
whatever nonsense they whatever concept
they invented and there you have the uh
rope model and what is that well you
have all these molecules they're bound
to each other so we're talking about
physical objects here
and they're twirling in place okay so
yeah they're right in the sense that
electricity
the electron does not move
move very it vibrates locally because
it's twirling in place okay it's like a
drill bit you know you you take the
drill bit you press the button and it
twirls in place
and yeah there's some vibration there
and that's what they're sensing okay
with their
measuring devices okay
and so they're sensing something locally
but
what what is moving around is not energy
it's you can call it torsion
but it's not torsion that's moving
around what's happening is the end of
the drill is drilling
okay so all you need to do is throw
something in place in situ
and whatever at the
point of contact that's what's gonna
have the effect of the torsion that's
why the light turns on
okay so this is the issue
so we got to keep it in the context
these people are saying first that the
electron beads roll around they don't
even have an atom to begin with but
let's assume that you know we have the
electron bead moving around then they're
saying it's not moving around what moves
you know moves very little from one atom
to another we don't know why what's
pushing that what's causing that little
b to jump from adam to adam that's the
first one but then on top of that you
know uh we they say that that's moving
very little what's moving is the energy
the field the
waves the whatever you know whatever
concept is moving around
and we're saying no uh what's happening
is you have something you have a drill
bit turning uh totally in place
and what you feel at the end what the
lamp or whatever power thing you're
powering is receiving is the torsion
of that whole um
i call it a serpentine that goes around
that whole snake that's what's twirling
on itself and that's what's causing the
uh the pressure on whatever uh
device you put you know at the end of
that whole circuit
okay
so that's uh electricity and that's
voltage okay
let's uh now go with the resistor so
what is a resistor under the rope model
okay here it is okay
uh here it is we have
a conductor
and it's twerting faster
the resistor is moving slower okay so
it's torquing it's twirling around in
situ at a slower rate
okay and you have all types of materials
some materials are more resistive
because their molecules are such that
they twirl slower than others conductor
twirls faster that's all we have okay so
we have faster twirl slower twirl that's
the difference between a conductor and a
resistor in a nutshell
okay and for that you know you need to
look at
you know in order to
understand it more deeply which i'm not
going to do today
is that you got to look at the molecular
structure of the thing used as a
resistor like these
metals that they have out there that
they put together with ceramics well you
got to look at
what is it in the crystal structure or
in the
molecular
composition of that substance that makes
it go slower than for example silver or
aluminum that's the issue okay so one is
swift
uh because of
uh it torques faster the other one's
slower because its molecules are such
that it twirls much slower that's all it
is okay that's electricity in a nutshell
a baby can understand it we're not
asking you to believe it we're asking
you to understand it
okay so here are the conclusions okay
we have uh first to reject
the notion that comes out of quantum and
classical mechanics
their mechanisms because they cannot
explain a single part of
any of their
assumptions or theories they cannot
illustrate their theory okay they cannot
illustrate any concept what are they
going to put for energy where are they
going to put for field what are they
going to use for you know charge these
are all numbers
okay and the definitions refer to
quantitative notions not the qualitative
you know uh things
you know objects that you can say okay i
can illustrate i can see the mechanism
like i you know you can see how a car
runs because you get the gas which is a
physical object it runs through the pipe
you know and then it goes up to the
front and it makes the the whole
mechanism work all the pistons and so on
we can all understand it because we see
every one of the objects and that's what
we want them to do with electricity we
say okay illustrate each one of the
objects that you mentioned illustrate a
field illustrate energy illustrate a
wave
illustrate charge
and i can't do that because these are
all concepts they're all quantitative
concepts
voltage is not a potential
whatever potential is i guess it's high
to low because that's what they talk
about that's how they illustrate it with
a water
analogy okay so no it's it's not a
potential is it pressure no it's not
pressure either there's no pressure
there's a chemical reaction at the ends
that
forces the whole serpentine to go
clockwise or counterclockwise that's it
okay
voltage again counterclockwise or
clockwise motion of merged molecules
that's what we're saying it is
uh current flow of electron beads
absolutely not
uh
flow of fields or energy hopefully not
otherwise you know maybe it is after 10
10 beers maybe it's the flow of energy
until
you drink those 10 beers you will not
understand flow of energy because
there's nothing to illustrate what are
you going to illustrate for flow of
energy or flow of fields what is a field
what is an energy okay illustrate it
then we'll know and um
current uh we say it's torsion of merged
molecules all these molecules are merged
uh all in rows i call them serpentines
because they form these long snakes okay
and so they twirled in situ that's what
we're saying torsion of in-situ
merged uh electron shells all the atoms
are bound to each other there's physical
connection from atom to atom otherwise
you don't get uh called
the torsion you don't get electricity
okay
and uh resistance
uh wall it's not the walls that impede
the flow of beads
okay or and i don't know any wall that
can can stop energy because we don't
know what energy is energy is a concept
of course there's no wall that can stop
energy or a field you can't stop a
number
from flowing
you can't even get the number to flow to
begin with okay
and resistance is wet low
speed torsions of merged electron shells
do we want you to believe it
absolutely not
what we want is for you to understand it
so that you can see
not only the difference between quantum
mechanics and what we propose
but so that you can get questions
ready for all those mathematicians who
know absolutely everything who proved
absolutely everything who have evidence
from experiments for absolutely
everything but they cannot answer a
single question
so those are the people that you have to
ask these questions to and say what do
you mean by this what do you mean by
that what do you mean by the other thing
can you illustrate it
and guess what
they won't be able to
okay let's get on with the questions
that we had since last time a lot of
people still are having major problems
understanding what an object is
my god how can this be so difficult and
yeah unfortunately that's the case
we have some people who have who are
stuck on the word object and i keep
saying the word object destroys all
religion
once you define the word object all
religions die
they suffer a sudden death no one can
beat the word object no one who's got a
religion can be and that's why people
are
you know that's why they attack the word
object because they realize
that's going to kill their religion it's
going to rape their virgin okay and they
don't like that okay okay so here it is
paul says it represents the idea of a
circle another fellow uh answer is
that's a drawing where is the that in
reality other than the screen talking
about a circle right and the other guy
says like
like is the drawing of a tree a tree
well the issue here is that a tree the
word tree is always
an
object okay
so when you say tree it's an object you
can't say well it's a drawing of a tree
an object
if you can if if you have a shape
because that's the definition of the
word object then it's an object i don't
care if it's a drawing
an illustration i don't care if it's a
real one i don't care if someone you're
imagining
which is not drawn which is not out here
the word tree
always represents an object i don't care
if it's in the land of the klingons you
can't see it or touch it it's it the
word tree represents an object it falls
under the category of objects
not under the
the heading known as concepts so we only
have two types of words in the
dictionary objects and concept it either
has shape or it don't
just that simple
so hash shape or does it one of the two
and so
if it has shape it's an object trees
have shape it's an object
i don't care if you can draw it i don't
care if you can imagine it i don't care
if you can touch it or see it on the
other side of the universe
the word tree always represents an
object yeah we got that that's the issue
but anyways here's a rundown that helps
us put it in the right perspective
word object is needs to be defined first
of all in physics you can't do a
physical interpretation without it
so you can't define the word exist at
the same time as the word object why
because the word object proceeds exist
because the word exists requires an
object plus location okay object also
precedes distance you need to have
the definition of distance requires two
objects the separation between two
objects it also precedes location why
because location is the set of distances
from one object to all others in the
universe or in the system under analysis
object also precedes motion you can't
have c or touch for example um define
object because you need to define object
before you define c or touch okay so the
word object precedes any motion because
motion is two or more locations of an
object
and also the word object precedes the
word concept because and a concept
requires two objects it's a
word that invokes two objects okay it's
a relation between two objects okay so
that's essentially the notion you need
to
before you can do the word object before
you can do any word in the dictionary
you need to define the word object for
the purposes of physics let's understand
that okay we're talking about science
here you're going to give a physical
interpretation in physics
you had better have an object otherwise
what is this so-called physical
interpretation
are you going to use field and energy
concepts to do a physical interpretation
you're going to use the word force to
say i pulled on the horse how did you
pull on i pulled it with a force
a force is a force of course of course
and nobody knows what a force is of
course right
okay here we have another fellow in
trouble with the word object lots of
people
troubles with them says how do you know
that which has shape you imagine or draw
it and if you can you know it has shape
for
sure
each and everything that has shape you
can imagine and draw
yeah that's why
uh an object is that which has shape
which it precedes that which you can
imagine or draw
okay
and guy says uh shape it will draw and
imagine
prove me wrong
well aside from the fact that we don't
prove in science okay uh we don't do
proofs okay
uh that's religion
uh here we have an answer to this
gentleman okay uh we're saying that he's
uh drawing around in circles
okay so this poor fellow you know he's
just going around in circles with his
drawing thing because uh he's drawing
something and then he says see i drew it
that means it's an object and only
because i drew it
or the other way around you say it's an
object because i was able to draw it
and now it has shape because
after i finish drawing meaning you
take your time you know
i was able to you know
see it or visualize it or now it has
shape okay
and yeah the problem again is that the
word object precedes
uh
verbs such as drawing that's one issue
and then i can't wait for you to draw a
circle especially the circle that uh
what's his name um
aristotle and all the greeks came up
with that they say uh what it what is a
um and they still have that definition
more or less today what is a circle well
it's a bunch of points uh equidistant
from a center or something along those
lines their case i think was euclid said
it's all these rays all these lines
that extend
from the center point
but then they tell you that between any
two lines between any two points there's
always another line another point
so these guys are still building their
infinite circle
you know i want them to come back when
they when they completed their circle
but you know euclid is still building
his circle to this day because he's
still putting one point between any two
points or one ray you know one line
between any two lines
so when he finishes you know up there in
in heaven or hell wherever he is at uh i
want him to come back and with a
finished product then we'll know what a
circle is right now they're still
building the circle so are the
mathematicians of today so yeah yeah
no we don't draw because we can't wait
for you to draw
we need a finished product
okay while you're drawing go ahead and
draw all you want but uh
we can't wait for you we've got other
things to do but when you finish drawing
the tree we want to see the finished
tree
okay don't tell me you're still drawing
it because i can't wait
okay so here's a thought experiment okay
for those people who have trouble
understanding the word object okay or
because they realize it destroys their
religion okay here's a thought
experiment okay
there's a single sphere in space
right that's all there is there's no god
no spirits no energy no mass no force
all there is in the universe in this
universe this universe that uh is out
there okay it's just a single sphere
made out of a single piece
okay we we got the vision more or less
okay it's the only object in the
universe okay this universe is comprised
of spear and nothing that serves as a
backdrop
in other words uh
nothing is the backdrop because nothing
is space and space is that which has no
shape okay so we have
a
ball
made of a single piece okay
and space serving as backdrop that's the
thought that's what you have to imagine
okay visualize it as best you can close
your eyes drink a beer whatever you need
to do but that's what you need to
visualize okay
there is no artist to draw or imagine it
okay
the sphere is there that's the universe
as it is this universe that
you know is out there you have this ball
in space that's all there is there's no
god
no drawer no artist
okay
and the question is we have shape we
have no illustration no one drew
anything there no one to draw it
okay oh we have a shape we have no
observers no one to ponder the shape
the ball has shape before you ponder it
it already has shape
okay so
it's not like you're gonna go in there
say let me draw the ball so that you
know that it has shape no the ball
already had shape before you start you
before you draw the pencil before you
existed before god made you okay so it's
just the universe as it could have been
instead of the one uh with stars playing
etc the sphere has shape
okay
and imagination and drawing will have to
wait until god appears
until god appears we cannot talk about
drawing we cannot have imagination
nothing nothing whatsoever all we have
is a ball out there
in space that's the only that's the
entire universe
okay maybe it's a parallel universe okay
so
there's no observer
no artist to draw it
the thing already has shape before the
artist came in with his
pencils or whatever he uses
brushes
okay
fella
what do you mean by shape
oh god poor fellow
uh
you know the their brains must be
so thick okay
bill this is a legitimate question i
would say essential oh okay
the form is the external appearance with
which each corporeal or fantastic object
or a representation of it is configured
yeah yeah yeah
this is the only issue i mean we can go
out forever with with these people
because they don't have the capacity to
understand what i'm saying the only
issue before us
is to see
touch or shape that's it which one are
we going to do to see or touch or shake
that is the question okay so if you can
understand that you're you're safe okay
uh we need no no observer
okay we need no artist to draw all we
need to know if a tree the word tree
represents that which has shape
and if it represents that which has
shape
then it's an object
and
these people are saying instead that
mathematical physics because that's the
default is c touch
that an object is that which you can see
and touch
and so the only issue here is not what
is shape what is c what is touch we
don't need to know any of that the
normal
ordinary
speech understanding of those words is
sufficient we just need to choose a
criterion or criteria okay
are we going to go with c touch which is
the default today or are we going to go
with shape
shape is a universal property all
objects have shape
not all objects can be seen not all
objects can be touched especially the
ones on the other side of the universe
okay so
that's it and if you don't understand
that you don't understand the context
so first understand the context before
you ask
nonsensical questions such as what is
shape did you miss kindergarten or what
you never learned the difference between
you know
a cube
and a sphere
the difference between these is shape
okay so if you don't understand that
well go to kindergarten they'll teach
you the difference between you know a
cube and a sphere and then you'll know
what shape is very simple
if you never learn shape well i'm so
sorry you know for you
okay another file says the law of
identity
the law by the law the people have been
so much nonsense okay and although this
comes from our great grandfathers you
know the greeks
and they came up with this nonsense and
it was carried out through all the ages
i mean how much nonsense can humans
create
and yeah the law of identity and you
look it up it says in logic the law of
identity states that each thing is
identical with itself
no kidding oh my
i guess these guys must have broken
their brains coming up with this
nonsense
you know i'm equal to me well that's
great
it is the first thing uh first of the
historical three laws these are laws
whoa by god i guess of thought along
with the law of non-contradiction in the
law of excluded middle one of those
nonsense is i don't even want to look
those up i'm scared
one such system of logic is the
objectivism of ayn rand iran which is
based on just these three
yeah
laws
good ol ain't she she had no idea about
anything here was this lady
and she did a lot of politics a lot of
recommendations how the world should be
run
no no that is even philosophy philosophy
you have to explain purposes and reasons
okay
otherwise what's the purpose of
philosophy just give your recommendation
your opinion
is that what philosophy is this is this
what people who go to study philosophy
at the university
uh do they say oh i've got a good
recommendation you should eat more
veggies and less meat or you should vote
for republican not for democrat
is that what a philosopher is or you
should be a buddhist and not a christian
is that what philosophy is about
is philosophy just a way of thinking
well everybody's got a way of thinking
so we have eight billion philosophers
what makes aristotle different why do we
call him a philosopher and not me you
know i also have a way of thinking a
rotten way of thinking but
one way of thinking
at least
so in what way is aristotle a
philosopher and you ain't
i mean if if everybody's if philosophy
is just a way of thinking
opinions or you know this is my way of
thinking i have my philosophy if that's
what the notion of philosophy is then
what's different than you
from plato and aristotle and hume and
all these other so-called enran and some
of these other so-called philosophers
and so yeah the the problem with ayn
rand especially you know she came up
with this notion
that uh try to define the word object in
the word exist she got involved with
those two words because it's typically
regarded as a branch of philosophy known
as ontology
and
no absolutely not
the word object and the word exist
these two words belong exclusively to
physics exclusively
anyone even tampering with them a little
bit
has crossed the line into physics
whether they know it or not
so whenever you use the word object in a
scientific sense right not in ordinary
speech but if you want to talk
scientifically use the word object or
the word exist you have crossed the line
into physics and so in rand crossed the
line into physics but she never realized
that because she never defined
philosophy she didn't know what
philosophy is and she thought antaj was
a branch of philosophy when those two
aspects object and existence do not
belong to philosophy or to ontology they
belong strictly to physic they form the
foundations of physics and so here we
have mrs zane ranch he tried to define
these terms the best way she could
and uh she made a big mess of that right
because she included everything under
object she thought everything she called
it entity which is a synonym of object
and physics and so she talked about
entity and then she talked also about
existence not knowing really what it is
again she thought uh existence
eventually was
something that had to do with an
observer see touch and no that's not
existence
uh and that's why she became an atheist
and atheism is unscientific as well
because the atheist follows the
mathematical method which is see touch
uh observe
do experiments do equations none of that
has anything to do with physics or with
science science is explanation you have
to explain a mechanism in physics and in
philosophy you have to explain reasons
someone did something to purpose
okay so here we have these uh great
philosophers we call them philosophers
of antiquity from greek greece and says
the earliest recorded use of the law law
of identity right appears to occur in
plato's dialogues okay and where in
socrates attempts to establish that what
we call sounds and colors are two
different classes of things
things
what things these are not things these
are concepts no such object called sound
no such object called color okay
socrates with regard to sound and color
in the first place do you think this
about both
do they exist how can they exist how can
sound exist
how can uh color exist if they're not
physical objects and you have to be an
object first before you can exist
concepts don't exist color is
frequency or wavelength of light
and sound is vibrations
typical one of air right that's it
rarefaction compression of air
so it's uh both of these are mechanisms
they're dynamic concepts both color and
sound so there's no physical standalone
object called color
and no physical standalone object called
sound now you can have stand-alone
object called
paint but
the red
in paint that's not a standalone object
but see these people started talking
about things and saying that they exist
because they never define what a thing
is and what exists means okay that's the
problem and fellow says yes okay then do
you think that each differs to the other
and is identical to itself
and the other guy says certainly
yeah because he didn't have the brains
to challenge
existence or the word object and that
both are two and each of them one in
other words each one is individual but
uh you know that they are separate they
are two separate things not equal to
each other yes that is true okay
and uh then we have mr
arie aristotle comes back and he goes in
there and um talks about in one of his
writings as well and says when a belongs
to the whole of b
and to c it is affirmed of nothing else
and b also belongs to all c it is
necessary that a and b should be
convertible for since a is said of b and
c only and b is affirmed both of itself
and of c it is clear that b will be said
of everything of which a is said except
a itself
i need a beer to understand all that mr
aristotle was way over my head okay my
pay grade so i won't even try to analyze
it but yeah they invented this nonsense
called uh the identity uh law of
identity very scary stuff
you know i thought people had something
better to do than all these
inventing all these laws
i'm sorry i'm sure that god and mother
nature the devil they're all rolling in
there where wherever they are now
okay another fellow sir chief my gps
couldn't work it wouldn't work if
relativity didn't work
so he thinks that um
relativity is proven because gps works
lots of people think that a lot of
people think that my computer wouldn't
work if quantum were wrong this is the
nonsense they come up with the illogical
logic they use okay and so there's
relativity proof that time is a physical
object which is what
what relativity says
time is warped like a hammock because
it's a physical object it's warped and
that's how they are going to show that
uh the earth or the moon don't fly out
of the solar system
and time comes up against the skin of
the earth is that what time is
is that what uh relativity proved that
time is a physical object
so you know when you say gps wouldn't
work if relativity were wrong
what you're saying is that relativity
proved that time is a physical object
because that's how they treat it they
say time is warped like a wall that you
see there
and the earth doesn't fly out of the
solar system because of warp space what
do we mean by that well it's the
roulette mechanism
they're saying that the little ball goes
around the roulette because it can't fly
out of the wall that's preventing the
little ball from flying out of the
roulette
do we have that
that's that they even illustrate it like
that so i don't know what part you don't
understand so yeah that's that grid down
there at the bottom that the space time
that's time
warp time
and that's why the earth comes up
against warped time and doesn't fly out
of the solar system
that's the mechanism that relativity
proposes for gravity for why the earth
doesn't fly out of the solar system
so is that what they proved with gps
that time is a physical object that
serves as a wall that comes up against
the skin of the earth prevents it from
flying out of there
okay we're talking about mechanisms here
forget about all the math all the
nonsense all the experiments we talk
about that we need an explanation for
why the earth doesn't fly out of the
solar system very simple very simple
stuff baby stuff once you illustrate you
know the pulley as long as you don't
have the rope it's magical
but once you put the rope there's oh
that's baby stuff he pulled down the
robe and that's why the box went up
same thing here
why doesn't the earth fly of the uh
solar system well we don't know because
there's something mystical between the
earth and and the sun
and so they say it's warped time what do
you mean warp time yeah see time is
warped and that's what general
relativity proved with their equations
and what is it the gravity probe b
proved with an experiment and earth
doesn't fly out because there's this
warp wall of time
that comes up against the skin of the
earth squeezing me you know because
i guess it's it's up against the earth
surface and i'm on the surface
so here's this time squeezing me
preventing the earth from flying out of
the solar system
this is the explanation from
general relativity
and don't tell me it's not don't tell me
i'm putting words in their mouth this is
the physical interpretation today from
uh general relativity if you've got a
different explanation i'd like to hear
it
don't tell me i'm wrong and i'm
misinterpreting making fun of general
relativity i'm telling you how it is
general relativity says
the earth doesn't fly out of the solar
system like you saw it illustrated there
it comes up against a wall that prevents
the earth from flying out that wall is
caused by the depression
uh caused in turn by the sun weighing
down space time
bending time
just like i'm saying it
okay so they're bending seconds and
that's what prevents the earth from
flying out so that's the explanation
that's the physical interpretation i'm
not putting words in their mouth i'm not
raising straw men
i'm saying it like it is literally
okay another fellow here says
ah what did i do with it i don't know
what happened to that one okay
that says here
there are
10 to the 82nd power atoms in the known
universe how many ropes
what diameter would that make this
invisible intangible physical thread
well uh how many atoms are there in the
and he said 82nd power that's a big
number you know 82 zeros
and i don't know how they calculated
that because we don't even know how big
the universe is maybe he's talking about
the
visible universe again the known
universe as far as the telescope can
reach
see
there are many atoms in this room you
know here here's uh here's my magic wand
god's magic wand okay
this is what i do my magic with and uh
how many atoms do you think are in this
little wand
well i can tell you first for a fact
there's
gazillions of atoms here
there's millions and millions of atoms i
i never counted them but
atom is so small
that in that little wand alone you got
millions of atoms
let alone in my room let alone on earth
let alone in the sun
let alone in the universe i mean we're
talking about
so many atoms
that
your calculator would burn just trying
to calculate that i think it's you know
you can take that number 82nd
and multiply or put that to the 82nd
power and you'd be even safer to say
that our 82 to the 82
second power
second level power of atoms in the
universe there's so many atoms we can't
even imagine
so what's the point
the point is that everything in the unit
let alone forget about atoms stars how
many stars are there well there's
gazillions that are trillions of stars
in our galaxy alone there are maybe a
trillion stars each one with
gazillions
for lack of a better number you know of
atoms
so yeah there's many
and
you just found out that the universe has
many atoms
and so if it has many atoms yeah so it
has many ropes and you say well how big
are how how wide are they how thick are
they well how thick is an atom three
angstroms
and and that's kind of small isn't it
you say how can it be so small i can't
see it i can't touch it yeah so
we've known that for a while we can't
see a hydrogen atom
and so you can't see a hydrogen so you
say well it doesn't exist it's not an
object because i can't see it or touch
it or whatever you know and how many are
there well there's gazillions of those
you know
and so there are many atoms and there
are many ropes that's it many is the
word
i never counted how many there are out
there okay
so
since i didn't count them i can't tell
you how thick they are either i mean you
would know uh how uh
i mean if you had to answer the question
how how wide how thick how big is a
photon
what is it zero dimensional that's what
the quantum
people say
you know a point particle
so yeah
i mean once you give me an answer for
the photon how big a photon is
how much mass it has
then uh maybe i can answer the question
as well okay so yeah it's a small
that's that's the answer yeah
one of these guys is very small so don't
even don't even try to calculate how big
it is
okay uh
paul says
the term rational is a religious term
used to label
notions build supports
[Laughter]
love it
okay let's find out what it is here's
the definition of rational we define
irrational instead same thing it's the
opposite of irrational uh but if you
treat a concept as an object known as
reification or concretization well then
you're doing irrationality that's the
main one but there you have the criteria
there's five criteria at least maybe a
guy smarter than me can come up with a
couple more but that's we do have a
definition for the word rational or
irrational okay so it's not like uh we
are arbitrarily coming up with
definitions we have a definition that we
can support we're saying anyone who
moves a concept is doing irrationality
not even religion it's it's even worse
than religion because religion you can
say again like i said earlier is
imaginable as long as you present the
objects but you know anyone who's moving
concepts around he cannot even justify
the objects he doesn't even start with
objects he doesn't have an object so
what kind of physical interpretation is
he going to give if he's going to be
using words such as energy and field and
force and
charge
you know what what kind of
physical interpretation is that when all
these are values numbers quantitative
concepts
which
in turn are dynamic concepts in every
case okay
okay uh thousands
says i don't understand pulling by the
gravity rope but i understand pulling
when a donkey pulls a rope because a
donkey has muscles yeah you can see all
the objects you can see the
donkey pull
maybe he's got some range or whatever
and pulling on the cart we can all see
that we can understand because all the
objects are visible so we understand it
just by looking
and that's how we should look at
everything in physics we should be able
to see even those invisible objects we
just have to make them visible that's it
so if you're going to do photons no
problem but make it visible and if
you're going to put a dot don't tell me
it's zero dimensional
because you put a dot that's not zero
dimensional
it's got something obviously it's an
object you can't say it's got no mass no
size
no no with no diameter but it's an
object no no if you're gonna use a dot
we've got an object already you can't
later take it back and say well it's not
an object zero dimensional it's got no
shape
okay that's a contradiction
either hash shape or doesn't have shape
if it has shape then you can represent
it with a dot or whatever you want a
brick
but you can't you can't take it back and
later say oh but it's not an object no
because then you're you're doing your
rationality why because you're moving
concepts around but he says how can we
and inert mass pull another mass how
does pulling work through the
gravitational rope okay
it's not the gravitational rope it's
called the electromagnetic rope but
that's okay we understand okay you can
call it whatever you want i have trouble
visualizing it but i can visualize a
donkey pulling on a rope okay i have no
trouble visualizing the gravity rope
it's in the video but how does the pull
mechanism work
okay
i can also visualize the mechanism of
magnetism pulling and pushing
to
so is the gravitational rope made of
magnetism that attracts other magnetic
objects or objects made of ropes
okay well let's go with one let's go
with the gravity so that we address that
issue that's the main one we want to
address and so let's go with that
and here it is okay
i explained this in the past it's got to
do with this notion of weight and that
puts it in the right perspective okay so
here it is we have weight is equal to
the gravitational constant mass mass
divided distance squared that's the
equation of weight
uh they say it's a force no weight is
not a force because that same equation
that you're staring at there
has no force there's no motion all you
have is distance between two objects we
have two masses as they call them two
objects and there's distance between
them and at that point they already have
weight because you can calculate the
weight you don't need to wait on the
on the scale
you already have weight you can
calculate the weight of those two masses
as long as you know what the masses of
how much they weigh
because that's what mass is the weight
and the distance between them in other
words if you have so many atoms
okay 100 atoms in one 200 atoms in the
other
and you have certain distance between
them you can calculate the weight
okay you can calculate the weight of one
object with respect to the other because
you have the masses which are the number
of atoms and if you knew how much each
atom weighs right then you can calculate
that weight
and it weight that weight is only valid
for a given distance a given separation
okay if you separate them a little more
or get them closer together
all bets are off you no longer have the
same weight you no longer have that
value there okay that weight is only
valid for a given distance a given
location
uh
static concept okay so weight is a
static concept let's get that straight
first right off the bat you don't need
to weigh anything you just calculate it
and you can calculate the weight of
something okay
and that's the first issue but then
what's the other issue since it's
location specific all you're looking at
is how many ropes
from the object that's got 200
atoms to the one that's got 100 atoms
how many ropes are interconnecting those
two objects
and all you need to do is find out how
many independent ropes the closer they
are distance closer they are the more
the ropes branch out
and the farther apart they are the more
they come together and that's what you
see there with the astronaut okay at a
different distance from the earth he's
got fewer and fewer independent ropes
participating in this
uh tug of war
okay and so this is not a force
weight is a tension
what do i mean by that i mean that only
for a given location do you have a
certain weight
that means every rope is tense no one is
pulling there is no pull in gravity so
get the word pull out of your mind we
use the word pull because
for
ordinary speech we say yeah gravity
pulls you down or whatever but that's
not the notion if you want to really get
to the bottom if you want to understand
it
every rope is simply under tension two
atoms are under tension think of it as a
bar made of a single piece united in two
uh like a dumbbell you know two two
balls there that's it so there's no
motion think of it as a single piece and
there's just static there
okay so that's tension tension means
that there is no one wins the tug of war
no one's moving in any direction because
there is no motion in that equation
all you have is two atoms separated by
distance in this case the rope uh is
what's between the two objects so the
rope is equal to distance distance is
equal to rope under the rope model okay
so what are we saying here there's only
tension
there's no pull
and for every location
you have a different weight
so meaning a certain number of ropes
that are acting independently okay so
the farther an object is
at infinity at a great distance
all the ropes essentially come together
and form a single coaxial for a given
location
farther out different
issue but
as that object approaches the other one
which we call pull
what we have is for different locations
we have tension
and you can calculate the weight for
every location the closer an object is
to another
okay so we have so uh this weight thing
this motion thingy that we think gravity
is acceleration of gravity is really
a an aggregate of locations of one
object with respect to the other as they
get closer the rows fan out so what
happens is objects drift
towards other objects
and when you look at
pull you have to get rid of the word
parole and think of static notions of
location at different distances
okay and so you have different weights
at different distances different weights
at different locations
and it's the summation of that which we
call acceleration of gravity so there is
no pull there is no acceleration of
gravity in that sense there is there's
only drifting because
more and more ropes participate as the
objects get closer to each other
and i don't know how else to explain
that okay
okay i hope not for you to believe it's
for you to understand okay
and we have a final question here let me
see if i can get rid of this give me a
second here
okay one more question i think yeah
and here it is false says
ah let's go to the other side
uh says
says definition of sound equal that
which is audible is that correct
and you know no if there's no one to
hear the tree fall into forest
there was no sound
so we have to look at the word sound
what is the definition of the word sound
to be able to answer your question sound
a vibration that propagates as an
acoustic wave through a transmission
medium
such as gas liquid or solid
does it mention anything about ears
or observers or people or
animals
plants maybe
no
sound is what a vibration that
propagates
so if the tree falls in the forest
was there sound
well according to the definition there
was sound
there was sound because it caused a
vibration in the air
i wasn't there but god was there
remember god is always there god's
everywhere right
so if god hears it we caught sound okay
not if you hear it
[Laughter]
with that i'll see you on sunday we'll
see you then